who is my jokester boyfriend Julian
we've been together first somewhere
around like E&F yeah your change
and we've been together for three years
- Scott we're going to muscular going
muscular like he I know that he's not
muscular already he definitely has like
that our definition yeah I guess if you
can just age your whole I'd like to see
like a wrinkly and such a little
definition in his arms okay let's give
her some biceps give him some like 90's
boy band look like maybe some frosted
tip what he actually looks like is Fred
from scooby-doo slight fro with the
plates you know like Aerosmith maybe
like a beard but in fact if that doesn't
work like a pink Nicki Minaj type of wig
soulless white I guess it raised his
eyebrows to mark match the excitement
out yeah drastic Tim and his anyway just
to make up really big lips I mean take
over his face just even burger I really
like what's off has sort of short hair
yeah if you can make it a duck more
please thank you that was great
thank you I think she's gonna like it
we'll see
you gave me eggs why no I made you all
my face is a little redder
I made you tanner where did my hair go
why I give a little bit of a cut you
like it yeah I definitely have a pink
wig instead of a gray hat it really
looks like I have a bigger bar it's not
that bad
so I kept I had ten leg and I also love
that you know I got something like The
Fresh Prince of bel-air haircut gon give
you that V oh that V oh my god go on
look amazing I could look like this all
the time no obviously the elephant in
the room is that she gave me blond hair
okay I'm gonna be huge by size I have an
explanation for this one you know this
is this makes me look like an action
hero
I'd love to turn that I'll give you a
big juicy sexy loud so that if I can't
yes I love it so she gave me I don't
know if it's higher cheekbones or a
smaller point to your mouth she's given
me a beak light feature I feel like I
put a little more effort into yours what
my point is that like you know if you
get a little jacked you know I love is
stronger Livermore Michelle Rodriguez
what's the little of you baby